Hey Youtubers it's Charlie so for my game
of thrones bonus video this week, talk all
about Brynden Rivers the Bloodraven you also
probably know him as the three had Raven just
careful for spoilers for everything this happen
on the show so far and there is a new round
of the giveaway starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so in case you missed
the news earlier this year Max von Sydow has
been recast as the three had Raven that person
it's helping train ran underneath the giant
weir would why they recast the character if
they already had somebody than the season
for with as a number reasons the game of thrones
recast roles one the actor that played the
character previously is unavailable because
they did something crazy or they passed away
or they are too ill or two they've expanded
the part and they need someone that they feel
like is a stronger actor my guess is is that
were gonna see a whole lot of three I Raven
scenes and is going to be a big speaking part
so they wanted to get a much bigger actor
enter Max von Sydow nine I put up this meeting
picture but that doesn't necessarily mean
that the characters evil is definitely a lot
of book theories about where the three had
Raven's allegiance lies to the great other
to the red God to the old gods technically
them being greenseers I would think that their
loyalty is to the old gods never three had
Raven has had a bunch of different names he
lived a very long life is a mortal man for
the largest part of his life like this last
big chunk he's been living as the three had
Raven though he was born the pastor Brynden
Rivers to Melissa Blackwood and Aegon Targaryen
the fourth that was the Targaryan that had
six mistresses a whole bunch of bastards that
sparked the first Blackfyre rebellion to just
placing the timeline with other big characters
that Martin has written stories about he predates
dunk and egg but even though he's around doing
things in west roast during the time dunk
and egg stories happening they don't really
cross past like he's not really part of those
stories the dunk and egg stories mostly just
follow dunk and egg in the people that they
interact with now later in life he went to
the wall became Lord Commander then became
the three eyed Raven before the earliest part
of his life he was only known as Brynden Rivers
the reason is called the Bloodraven is because
as a child he was born with this birthmark
over his face even though he was a great warrior
he kind of opted for more scholarly pursuits
so he gained powers of magic like a gain the
power to clamor himself you to make himself
look like other people think of him as being
like a combination of Samwell and his younger
brother like very studious but also a very
good warrior so the first big saga of his
life is the Blackfyre rebellion I've really
done a video about that so put a link in the
description the pastor that started the Blackfyre
rebellion was Daemon Blackfyre Brynden's half-brother
by another woman there's always a lot of resentment
when it comes to bastards especially when
a keying has a number of sons he's is always
going to favor one son more than the other
so Brynden Rivers was one of those more favorite
sons awake on the fourth Kiva Valyrian blade
dark sister to Brynden Rivers dark sister
was the Valyrian blade that originally belonged
to the send you Targaryen and she is one of
the sister wives of Aegon the first Aegon
the conqueror he also gave the sword of succession
the Blackfyre ancestral Valyrian blade to
Daemon Waters not to his legitimate heir that
he had with his wife all kinds of resentment
and drama months all the brothers bastards
and legitimate if for those that are asking
the whereabouts of dark sister are still unknown
like like bitter steel took the Blackfyre
that ancestral Targaryen blade the other big
Valyrian blade the later in life when Brynden
Rivers went to the wall nobody knows if he
took dark sister with them so the blades whereabouts
are completely unknown wouldn't it be cool
though but somewhere underneath that we or
would there there might be a Valyrian blade
somewhere nearby so keep your eyes peeled
the second big era in his life was when he
served as hand of the king to multiple Targaryen
and King's of the person to name him hand
of the king wasn't originally the brother
that he sighed with during the Blackfyre rebellion
but he did serve on that brother small counsel
sees a look at it as a reward for siding with
the crown like hey you said it with us instead
of siding with the Blackfyre so work in a
name you to the small counsel that Targaryen
King died his successor became heiress the
first that person was the one to name him
hand of the king maker the first eventually
became king he served through his reign and
when he died Brynden Rivers acting as hand
of the king called the great council to decide
who should be the next king there was this
big issue of succession eventually Aegon the
fifth was chosen know know him as egg from
the Dunk and egg series so like little egg
here was Aegon the fifth because of some shading
this that happened at that great council Aegon
the fifth egg had Brynden Rivers imprisoned
and thrown in the black cells would happen
is is the Blackfyres were still a big thing
in the east and they wanted to treat peacefully
with the crown like they wanted to bury the
hatchet but when one of the Blackfyres arrived
to treat with a great council he was arrested
by the goal cloaks and beheaded so no hatchet
being buried there the Blackfyre still hate
the crown later egg gave him the option of
taking the black he accepted so he went to
the wall within about six years of that he
became Lord Commander of the nights watched
so Brynden Rivers who was the Bloodraven became
part of the small counsel then handed the
king then became Lord Commander of the nights
watched but after about 13 years as Lord Commander
of the nights watched disappeared wall ranging
north of the wall that was almost 50 years
before the events of what's happening on the
show right now so presumably when he disappeared
north of the wall he was just embracing what
he thought was his path is the last green
seer think of him as being like the engine
start before Benjamin Stark existed all the
benches Stark is not a green seer he does
go north of the wall one day ranging disappeared
never to be seen again no I think I've said
it before but the interesting thing is is
that when he went to the wall originally when
Brynden Rivers took the black went to the
wall he was also accompanied by may start
a man who at the time took the black because
they were way too many Targaryen and heirs
of the time Maester Aemon was one of Aegon
the fifth's brothers he was originally chosen
as a candidate to become the future king during
that the great council but he ceded to his
younger brother egg so in previous seasons
when we heard Maester Aemon talk to Jon Snow
about duty to family and when John here's
what happened to Ned Stark what's going on
with Rob Stark he wants to go help them mainstream
is like I know exactly which are going through
I had to watch the downfall of my family at
the hand of the mad King that that doesn't
even begin to get into greensight all the
things that he's going to be doing with Brynden
Stark in season six but just vacation not
sure their skin changing and then there's
greensight so the ability to skin changes
something that's passed down genetically amongst
people with DNA from the first minutes it's
like a first man thing but I think the numbers
like one in every 1000 people that are born
with the ability to skin change are also born
green seer's that's also genetic but you know
being born a skin changer is a very rare think
the chances of being born in a green seer
are almost impossible so it's incredibly rare
and that's why until brand comes along the
Bloodraven is called the last green seer skin
changing just allows you to quota quote where
the skins of other biological creatures greensight
is a much more broad-spectrum power over nature
that they did some really cool things that
I'd I don't want to spoil at of season six
we might end up opening season six with like
a really special greensight sequence to stay
tuned for that but if you want to read more
about brand learning about greensight in the
three had Raven then reread dance with dragons
that's when most of those chapters happen
here's my big question if you guys let me
know in the comments do you think that they're
going to address this big grand history that
the Bloodraven's had 40 think it's going to
be like they did with Maester Aemon where
he just references it like I have had to witness
a lot of very sad history and my family there
a lot of shows the do that like kind of brush
over a lot of history with a really simple
turn of phrase it so sometimes is effective
sometimes a kind of sucks I think a really
good example of it is during the flash season
one went varies confronting the reverse flash
and he asked some flat out why you done all
this why you trying to hurt my family why
do you hate me so much in the reverse flash
really coldly just replies it doesn't matter
so be prepared for the show in even the books
for that matter cannot fully explain things
most of the history of the Bloodraven is covered
in the expanded materials that can be read
world of ice and fire and then you read the
Dunk and egg series like you hear about a
lot of things happening in and around his
life I think wins a winner's gonna be a really
big book for that character so odds are forgot
to learn more about his history it can happen
in that book still crossing my fingers on
a late March early April release on wins a
winner will hopefully it'll drop like right
before season six a game of thrones drops
but congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner blue sky you and a $20 Amazon gift
card be sure to private message me on the
back and my channels and get your contact
info was can happen next is is we are like
dangerously close to viral trailer territory
we get the teaser for Jon Snow last week from
HBO to just expect more cryptic teasers in
the next couple of weeks first trailer though
do not expect that before February just in
case you haven't seen it I did a whole big
video about that Jon Snow teaser that HBO,
you can click here for all about that and
you can click here for last night's midseason
finale from walking dead thank you so much
for watching, everybody high five and I'll
see you guys tonight!